here UMP is decided to become a man of
his word at the worst possible time this
week I just thought he was saying all
that when he was trying to get elected
Vinnie was very like ask and I was going
to coach for four years I didn't know he
was going to go in turbo mode so he made
good on his insane plan to ban Muslims
from entering the United States and
literally everyone hates it why just
look at this tweet from 2015 calls to
ban Muslims running the u.s. or
offensive and unconstitutional I wonder
if Trump's going to come across this Lib
tard named uh Mike 10 whatever American
I'm selling a real name Americans came
up by the thousands to protest at
airports sending a message that no ban
will be tolerated and also yes travel
can get worse but nice nice to have
everyone for rallying peacefully even
New York City cab drivers joined in
showing solidarity by refusing to take
parents to JFK during the protest now it
may pose a temporary inconvenience but
let me ask you something if you saw a
scene in the movie where a bunch of cab
drivers who normally don't give any
about anything and you just saw like all
of their off-duty lights flick on one by
one to processor City you would bawl
your eyes
oh I'm telling you you know you'd be at
home alone or you'll be on a plane why I
don't know like crying planes a lot for
some reason what a bunch of movies like
like there's still love in this world
like you would be so much the band is so
bad even thousand-year-old Robo villain
Dick Cheney came out against it take a
look
six genders angstroms bands against
everything we stand for guys people got
mad at uber for breaking the tactic
strike started the hashtag delete uber
and look we actually found that Dick
Cheney joined into that too here's
before he won on himself
I do imagine that's like let's see
Banias dick looks like that would make
sense
he is cold-blooded however other apps
did take action to show their opposition
of the Muslim band with lips pledging to
give a million dollars over four years
of the ACLU Airbnb yeah Airbnb offering
to house a refugees an Apple Maps
pledging to get Steve Ben and lost
comedians how should other apps make a
political statement Moshe kasher oh
actually inspired by Airbnb grinders
offering free holes for refugees to
stick their dicks into okay
[Applause]
yeah on tinder it is now positive to
swipe left but if you swipe right you
can only date your daughter okay fine
bye-bye Laird Arden myrin ah no matter
what address you put in we've is going
to give you the fastest route to Canada
all right you know is the I think we're
all touched by immigration in some way I
think if anyone had wanted to institute
a ban on immigrants it should have been
the Native Americans in the 1600s I mean
if we're really being granular about it
my mother's grandparents came here from
Italy they were not turned away they
were welcomed I'm here we're all touched
by immigration in some way so I hope
that we find compassion and that we
don't just go on a crazy witch hunt that
isn't going to work anyway
[Applause]